this is max also known as rinhari saki
he's our in-house breath of the wild
expert with over 2 300 hours in the game
he's created techniques has a 99-page
combat glossary and
even knows link's weight equivalent
there is actually different weights for
different items in
in breath of the wild like i know link
weighs
five apples and two spicy peppers
combined is like link's weight which is
just a weird fact
and today he's gonna be breaking down
some of the most viral breath of the
wild
clips and explain to us common folk just
how these ridiculous moves are being
pulled off
if you want to see max break down more
clips let us know in the comments below
and if you'd like
consider subscribing if you're not
already alright max
over to you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so he's doing a very intricate
setup for something that can be done
pretty easily in other ways well excuse
me
princess so first of all he's doing
something called a bomb flip which is
basically
in the holding stance where he has
something above your head like a rock or
a bomb or
a shrine puzzle like this if you do a
jump attack
with a heavy weapon while you're in the
air that attack will go over your head
so that actually knocks things backwards
so in that case
he already pre-damaged the weapon so
then when he does that weapon breaks and
it knocks it backwards
and then after that oh you know what he
did that because he wouldn't get landing
lag that's interesting
when you normally do a weapon flip like
that with two ended weapons
you'll slam the ground and that's that
ground slam takes a lot of time to get
out of
so he broke the weapon immediately so
then all i could do is just turn around
and stasis the
the puzzle which is really cool and then
he does two backflips and then he runs
forward it's probably for timing
purposes
but wasn't really necessary i guess he
could just
jump off of that because he wasn't
timing the puzzle bomb to go anywhere
he's just using it as a platform so he
doesn't really need to time anything but
it's interesting because then he does
a shield jump unequips a shield and then
he
bomb ragdoll jumps over the ledge again
it's a lot of intricate maneuvers for
something that can be done when like one
win bomb
there's a lot of stuff going on no i'm
not like a shrine running expert by any
means but this is pretty cool just watch
like this
[Music]
[Music]
okay so that's a pretty standard uh
crownist launch
when something is ragdolled or goes into
ragdoll state
there's some weird like glitch launch
properties around them so the weird
thing about guardians
is their body is actually always in a
ragdoll state
and their legs just kind of carry that
ragdoll state around so that's why you
can
use a crownist block to slow down time
and then launch that body way up into
the air like that you know the cool part
about this obviously is like you have to
aim the ancient arrows so it probably
took him a couple times to do that but
it's still cool nonetheless because that
guardian is spinning so
to get the head shot as it's spinning
not quite easy but i'm sure after a
couple tries you can get it i'm not
gonna lie there's actually a video that
cleric made
a while ago where oh no i'm sorry uh a
fan of cleric
uh made about the the reality of making
clips like this
dang it dang it
dang it how long has he been doing this
[Music]
three days dang it
the reality is it takes a couple tries
for sure
this is actually not as hard as it looks
well excuse me again princess
so there's a technique called switch
canceling breath of the wild basically
where as you parry you can switch
shields or weapons actually
and it will put you back to neutral
immediately after your switch so you
could just parry perry perry perry perry
back to back with no delay
this actually was easier because it was
a master mode and what master mode does
is
guardians will fake out shots so
sometimes they'll do just a direct shot
and sometimes it'll like
delay it to like kind of fake you out
the harder version is the master mode
version because some guardians will fake
you out and other ones won't so this
one's like a standard one where all the
guardians shoot at the exact same time
you can just pair
each one and it's pretty much going to
be the same every single time master
mode is a lot harder so
this is the easier version but it's
still cool it looks really cool when you
like destroy all the guardians at once
so ah pekko
okay so um let's start from like the
beginning here so the crusher lionel is
coming towards him
he usually does a sweeping attack which
is pretty low and that stuff
can be jumped over with a shield jump
again that shield jump is actually used
for shield surfing downhills but it does
give you a lot of height
upwards and if you unequip the shield
you get even a slightly more height so
that can be used to jump over attacks
like this he relocks onto the lynel does
a spin attack
here so he does a parry and it looks
really quick
because usually a parry lasts a long
time he's usually like a long animation
it's like a slow-mo it looks really cool
but he just parries and immediately gets
out of it which is called a crouch
cancel which is basically
the moment you parry and you crouch it
cancels that and then you can stand back
up so you just
hit parry crouch crouch so you're
immediately back up and you're ready to
go so it's actually a faster way to get
out of the parry animation so you can do
whatever you want at work afterwards
which is pretty cool
a really useful technique in just
regular high level combat
is to pull out your bow as you're
backflipping it's pretty common you'll
see in a lot of twitter clips that
you'll see a lot of players
back including myself that i'll backflip
drop a bomb and pull out your bow at the
same time
so now you've got your bow drawn and you
have a bomb in front of you
all ready to go so it sets up a lot of
techniques after that you can shoot your
bow and you can stasis
uh you can shoot your bow and then you
can jump forward and shield block reset
off the bomb they have in front of you
uh there's a lot of options after that
so basically he's just doing a whole
bunch of advanced stuff here back to
back
here it's not it's not really used that
often there's not a real technique named
for it yet
but you can shoot also in slow motion
too where you can shoot the bombs with
your arrows and it'll actually knock it
forward another common way to use that
is during updrafts you can
updraft drop the bomb turn around and
shoot the bomb
and that'll actually launch the bomb
forward you know farther than you could
ever throw it in this case
it's used on the ground you could just
shoot the bomb it'll just kind of roll
on the ground it actually would've been
more effective with the round bomb but
it's just
it's annoying to just keep switching
bomb types back and forth so it's just
cool to just kind of show off and just
push the bomb forward so you can blow it
up this is
actually pretty old footage it looks
like but petco's been consistently good
at just
on the fly fighting i'm i'm more good at
like setup
preset combat where i know what's going
on and what i know i'm gonna do but
there's a lot of fighters out there who
are just really good at being on the fly
like just kind of doing stuff depending
on what the enemy does
and uh you know lionel fighting is
there's a lot of that lynel fighting
this is uh
obviously some really good stuff so good
job pako
[Music]
not not too advanced but it just does
look really cool
he obviously has his bokoblin mask on so
he won't be detected
and what bokoblins or any enemies like
to do when you have a majoris mask or
enemy mask on is they just like to
circle around you so what he did here
was use urbosa's fury
and all the metal boxes and his
thunderblade to
obviously just do a whole bunch of
electricity damage at once so
it's interesting that he took off his
mask
he didn't really need to take off his
mask it just i don't know it just makes
it look cool again
a lot of the combat stuff again is just
for style you know there's there's no
like multiplayer online breath of the
wild so this is all just for style and
looking cool on twitter so
so what so what he did here was he
pre-placed all these items on the ground
um all the dragon parts and then he
pre-placed the bombs as well
so all those in a pile these are all
floatable objects which means that
when they hit an updraft so they will
fly with it rivali's gale
does stay you know updrafting for like
10 seconds or so
so he used that updraft to carry them
both
there is actually different weights for
different items in in breath of the wild
like i know link weighs five apples
and two spicy peppers combined is like
link's weight which is
just a weird fact but um yeah these
dragon parts
weigh differently than bombs so the
dragon parts took a little bit longer to
to meet up with the bombs once they do
it just looks really cool because then
you can bomb them
and then they whenever that item gets
launched then
by either just dropping it and rolling
or by you know getting launched by bombs
like this it'll just have this cool
sparkling effect it just looks like
fireworks which is
really cool so yeah just another neat
visual trick in breath of the wild
all right well that was fun to watch um
thank you guys
uh if you like this kind of content um
we have more on gamesbot's youtube
channel
and like and subscribe because there
will be more coming and for everything
else
stay right here on game spot
[Music]
you